[Música]
luego del anuncio de eeuu de retirar sus
tropas de afganistán es sin condiciones
antes de mayo y hasta el 11 de
septiembre alemania anunció este
miércoles que también sincronizará su
retirada al igual que la otan mientras
tanto francia como reino unido-
conversarán para determinar si se suman
a la iniciativa
el kremlin y respondió a la iniciativa
del presidente estadounidense joe biden
de una cumbre para desescalar el
conflicto de la frontera con ucrania
dijo que es prematuro hablar en términos
tangibles de una posible reunión pero
seguirá estudiando la propuesta tenemos
análisis de lo que allí sucede
tercera noche de protestas en mineápolis
por la muerte del joven afroamericano
down rights a manos de un agente de
policía quien renunció ayer a su cargo
este hecho se produce en momentos en que
se lleva a cabo el juicio por la muerte
de georg floyd ocurrida en mayo de 2020
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en 24 mi nombre
es y valencia- gracias por seguir con
nosotros iniciamos hablando del anuncio
del presidente de eeuu joe biden de
retirar sus tropas de afganistán hoy
alemania anunció que también
sincronizará su retirada al igual que la
otan
además tanto francia como reino unido-
conversarán para determinar si suman o
no a esta iniciativa el presidente joe
biden entregará más detalles este
miércoles y sostuvo que el proceso será
gradual e iniciará antes de mayo para
finalizar el próximo 11 de noviembre
cuando se cumplen 20 años de los
atentados contra las torres gemelas de
nueva york
nueva fecha para la retirada de las
tropas de estadounidenses de afganistán
según la casa blanca no quedará ningún
soldado de eeuu en suelo afgano para el
11 de septiembre de 2021 20 años después
de los ataques terroristas contra el
world trade center de nueva york y el
pentágono por parte de al qaeda eeuu
invadió afganistán buscando a su
entonces líder bin laden desencadenando
así su guerra más larga
el presidente ha sido consistente en su
opinión de que no hay una solución
militar para afganistán y llevamos ahí
demasiado tiempo
la nueva fecha retrasa el plazo
negociado por donald trump con el grupo
talibán que se cumple el 1 de mayo
dejando la incógnita de si los
islamistas cumplirán o no su promesa de
atacar objetivos estadounidenses a
partir de esa fecha el grupo talibán se
mantiene con fuerza en afganistán y sus
diálogos con el gobierno de kabul no
prosperan
un fracaso para eeuu que aspiraba a
dejar un país en paz
hasta que todas las fuerzas extranjeras
se hayan retirado completamente de
nuestra tierra el emirato islámico no
participará en ninguna conferencia que
tome decisiones sobre afganistán
actualmente hay 3500 tropas
estadounidenses en suelo afgano además
de otras 7.000 unidades principalmente
de países de la otan desde su inicio el
conflicto se ha cobrado la vida de dos
mil soldados de eeuu y ha herido o
matado a más de 100.000 civiles afganos
el que me sostuvo este miércoles que
considera prematura en términos
tangibles la posibilidad de una reunión
con el presidente de eeuu joe biden
luego de la propuesta desde washington
de una cumbre para desescalar la
atención y la frontera rusa ucraniana
luego de meses de tregua
las preocupaciones por el movimiento
constante de tropas son de todos los
lados tanto de craig ucrania como de la
otan y eeuu mira las tensiones crecen
desde comienzos de mes para hablar de
este tema y sobre el contexto esta
situación nos acompaña a alberto juzguen
roiter doctor en relaciones
internacionales profesor del instituto
de servicio exterior en la nación
argentina y de la universidad abierta
interamericana bienvenido a france 24
cuéntanos rusia y ucrania tienen un
conflicto desde 2014 cuando rusia se
anexó crimea a qué se debe este nuevo
ambiente de crispación en la región y
cuáles son los intereses actuales de
rusia
bueno yo creo que el contexto del
conflicto precede a la anexión o rico
relación de crimea en 2014 si bien es
cierto que 2014 las relaciones entre
occidente y rusia se volvieron cada vez
más dificultosas la situación de
escalada actual obedece a una serie de
acontecimientos entre occidente y rusia
que elevaron incluso en eeuu el nivel de
vigilancia a una situación de potencial
crisis inminente lo que es realmente muy
peligroso yo creo que hay que entender
que occidente del difunto de vista ha
llevado a una situación más allá de lo
recomendable al extender las líneas de
la otan a estas zonas geopolíticas rojas
de monstruo y desde este punto de vista
paramos un territorio un país
esencialmente geopolítico terrestre
cualquier situación que implique
acercarse
a líneas rojas como bielorrusia ucrania
y georgia implica una reacción en
términos de ganancia de poder que
incluyen la guerra de manera que el caso
el caso del opositor ruso alexéi navalni
también influyó en esta sección pero
básicamente para entender este conflicto
y su estado de gravedad hay que
encararlo desde la geopolítica luego hay
otras cuestiones pero sin duda en la
geopolítica en este tema muy sensible
para rusia el que actualmente ha llevado
la situación a una situación casi de
crisis inminente
bueno pues justamente hablando esa
crisis todos los actores en esta
escalada que son rusia ucrania estados
unidos de la otan se acusan entre sí de
la atención y cada quien tiene sus
propias razones como rebajar entonces
las tensiones cuando ninguno da un paso
atrás
bueno una de las características que
adquirido de este concepto en los
últimos años esto si yo diría que es
nuevo desde 2014 hasta hoy es que se ha
vuelto prácticamente irreductible el
conflicto quedan muy pocas líneas como
para encausar una negociación entre el
mandatario ruso que se ha mostrado un
poco frío en relación para prosport al
presidente norteamericano de abrir
negociaciones pero quedan algunas líneas
pero cada vez se están acortando más
puestos que rusia se ha iniciado
actividades militares en su frontera con
el donbass e incluso en crimea
pero también occidente ha llevado
adelante una serie de medidas que
preocupan al usar el mismo lenguaje que
ha utilizado el presidente
estadounidense poco tiempo ha irritado
sobremanera
el kremlin y las medidas que parece va a
llevar adelante eeuu en adelante son las
que preocupan a estados que
prácticamente en todos los frentes
produce a siente que occidente quiere
incrementar sanciones quieren presionar
a países de europa particularmente
alemania para que sean muy riesgosos
suministro de energía de luz de de rusia
a europa quiere prácticamente sancionar
a rusia en ámbitos financieros
internacionales crear normas para
sancionar a rusia hacer
a rusia particularmente el segmento
ciudad metidos etcétera puesto que desde
mi punto de vista occidente considera
que se encuentra en una etapa de
debilidad y por lo tanto es momento de
presionar
bueno pues muchas gracias por su
análisis interesante desde argentina
alberto julián reiteró que nos acompaña
esta mañana en france 24 continuamos con
más noticias porque el presidente iraní
hassan rohani habló de la decisión de su
país de enriquecer uranio al 60 por
ciento justo cuando avanzan en viena las
conversaciones que intentan reactivar el
acuerdo nuclear de 2015
rabbani calificó de terrorismo nuclear
el ataque a las instalaciones de la
central atómica en natanz de las cuales
culpa a israel incluso hemos anunciado
que activaremos la 76 en natanz o
aumentaremos el enriquecimiento al 60
por ciento esta es nuestra respuesta a
su maldad no se puede conspirar contra
la nación iraní y cometer crímenes en la
tarde hoy y razón y le cortamos la mano
cuando cometes crímenes te cortamos las
dos manos te cortamos una con las
centrifugadoras y la otra con el 60%
está claro que nos detallaremos
no esperaremos en eeuu el jefe del
departamento de policía brooklyn se
entere de minnesota así como la agente
que disparó mortalmente contra un joven
afroamericano durante un control de
tráfico renunciaron a sus cargos esto
mientras las protestas del movimiento
black light matter siguen sacudiendo la
ciudad la muerte del domingo de down
write de 20 años se produjo en un
momento en que la atención ya estaba
aumentando en el estado con el juicio en
curso el ex oficial del ex yo vine por
la muerte de georg florit
pues la madre de down y right relata la
última conversación telefónica con su
hijo momentos antes de que muriera a
causa de un disparo de un agente de
policía entonces cuando volví a llamar
la chica que le acompañaba en el coche
contestó al teléfono y estaba en
facetime y estaba llorando y gritando y
dijo que le habían disparado y apresuró
el teléfono hacia el asiento del
conductor un hijo estaba atendido allí
sin responder esta fue la última vez que
vi a mi hijo
junto a ella y a la novia de ride otra
familia afligida la de georges floyd
saliendo en juzgado donde se lleva a
cabo el juicio contra la gente de erecto
bing
siglos
variables minneapolis ya no pueden
barrer esto bajo la alfombra estamos
aquí lucharemos por la justicia para
esta familia igual que estamos luchando
por nuestro hermano
thomas steitz un supuesto error un
hermano por una pistola eléctrica es
inaceptable hasta cuando no ven es
defender la policía de brooklyn center
ha dicho que la gente que disparó
mortalmente al raid durante un control
de tráfico rutinario el pasado domingo
había disparado su arma por error
pensando que era una pistola eléctrica
la gente quin potter así como el jefe de
policía team canon que fue criticado por
calificar el suceso de accidente
dimitieron el martes el alcalde de la
ciudad dijo que esperaba que estas
renuncias ayuden a sanar a la comunidad
pero la policía antidisturbios y los
manifestantes se enfrentaron de nuevo
por tercera noche consecutiva y las
continúan los llamados a la justicia y
de edición de cuentas
el presidente de venezuela nicolás
maduro anunció el envío de 1.000
combatientes de las milicias nacional al
estado de apure en la frontera con
colombia donde se registran
enfrentamientos con disidencias de la
antigua guerrilla de la farc y la
guerrilla del eln el 21 de marzo pasado
la milicia nacional de venezuela está
conformada por civiles armados cercanos
al oficialismo
les ratificó la orden a la fuerza armada
nacional bolivariana y a la milicia
bolivariana en el estado apure de
aplicar la doctrina guerra de todo el
pueblo contra grupos irregulares y
terroristas colombianos unión
cívico-militar policial en defensa de la
soberanía venezolana cero tolerancia
los peruanos esperan la ratificación por
parte de las autoridades electorales
sobre los dos candidatos a la
presidencia que pasarán a la segunda
vuelta a los comicios del pasado domingo
con un 98,1 por ciento de las actas
escrutadas estos son los resultados el
candidato pedro castillo del partido
perú libre lleva la delantera con un
19,1 por ciento de los votos y desde ya
el candidato de extrema izquierda busca
alianzas con otros partidos
en segundo lugar keiko fujimori de
derecha por el partido fuerza popular
que registra un 13,3 por ciento de los
votos la candidata ha logrado de
reflotar su partido luego de más de un
año de prisión preventiva mientras se
investigaba los delitos de lavado de
activos y organización criminal se
espera que hoy anuncien los resultados
finales en la nación andina
y entre 6 y 7 millones de personas en el
mundo están contagiadas con la
enfermedad de chagas un males silencioso
que si no es tratada a tiempo puede
provocar importantes alteraciones
cardíacas y digestivas e incluso podría
ser mortal
este 14 abril se conmemora el día
mundial de esta enfermedad que es
endémica américa latina y donde causan
más muertes que cualquier otra
enfermedad parasitaria incluida la
malaria es una enfermedad silenciosa y
silenciada
así es como naciones unidas- llamada la
enfermedad de chagas un mal que puede
llegar a ser mortal si no se trata a
tiempo generalmente es asintomática se
desarrolla lentamente y afecta a
poblaciones pobres la enfermedad de
chagas afecta entre 6 y 7 millones de
personas cada año en américa latina es
una enfermedad silenciosa afecta a los
más pobres los más vulnerables y mata de
espacio en tantos seis millones mujer
cerca de dos millones de mujeres en edad
fértil se ven afectadas crónicamente
afectada escuchamos esta enfermedad que
sólo es diagnosticada al 7% de quienes
la padecen
es transmitida por la picadura del
insecto conocido como chinche del tri
atom ha infectado los alimentos
contaminados las transfusiones de sangre
transplantes de órganos o incluso de
madre a hijo algo contra lo que luchan
naciones unidas
en el día de la enfermedad de chagas y
unique age se enorgullece en anunciar el
lanzamiento de un nuevo programa de
eliminación de la transmisión de madre a
hijo en bolivia brasil colombia y
paraguay
que se enfocará en análisis tratamiento
de atención mediante seguimiento
sistemático a la mujer y al recién
nacidos la onu alerta sobre la necesidad
de dar a conocer esta enfermedad
tropical de la que poco se habla y de
los tratamientos que actualmente existen
para prevenir los fallecimientos que
anualmente rondan los 10 mil
y para finalizar damos un vistazo a
nuestra página web france24 punto con
nuestro portal informativo en cuatro
idiomas veamos entonces los titulares
recomiendan suspender en eeuu el uso de
la vacuna de johnson y johnson por casos
de trombos esta y más información del
acontecer internacional y también por
supuesto los programas preparados por el
equipo periodístico de france 24 en
inglés francés árabe y español
así finalizamos nos vemos más adelante
[Música]